it's very early in the morning and this
residential area looks like many others
in central to Iran but I know I have
come to the right place and enter into a
different world the morning prayer has
just begun and I watch in silence dozens
of men carry out Jewish right Wilford
are thousands of years old and have been
performed by Jews in the region for
almost as long the synagogue in Yousefi
but is one of the more than 20 working
synagogues in Iran's capital Tehran is
the center of Jewish life in Iran
housing a deeply traditional and
religious community after the Islamic
Revolution in 1979 its number decreased
significantly but with almost 9,000
members left all over the country it's
still the biggest Jewish parish all over
the Middle East outside of Israel and
its number is growing Jewish life in a
country under Sharia law with cartoon
competitions promoting Holocaust denial
the prayer continues but I leave this
synagogue to find out more about this
apparent contradiction and learn while
the Islamic Republic does not recognize
the Jewish state it does embrace the
religion itself as people of the book
Jews are a recognized minority in Iran
that means they can practice their
religion freely and even drink alcohol
as part of their religious ceremonies
but it also involves being set aside in
a separate but equal system which is
reflected in everyday life Jews can
either hold high offices nor be judges
so they are gradually pushing for more
rights and we're about to meet the man
who is responsible for that I find him
inside Iran's Jewish Hospital where see
a mock male federal works as a surgeon
whenever he's not in Parliament seeking
to improve the situation of Iranian Jews
according to the law there is some
limitation for the reduce minority in
Iran for example the reduced minority in
Iran cannot work in the army as an
official only for soldier they can go to
the army if someone want to work after
the soldier ending the soldier period in
the army they cannot do this for example
we want to change this and your drink
are our best changing that however does
not change the way he feels about his
country cannot define nationality only
by religion Armenia I was born in Iran
my native language is Persian I can't
speak in English but I can only think in
Persia but when I ask him what he thinks
about the presidential election this
Friday and what it means for Iran's Jews
he chooses his words carefully
according to the Iranian Jew there is no
difference because we are a part of
Iranian citizenship and everyone who
elected mats work in the framework of
the constitutional law so there is no
difference according to our religion but
of course in our community there are
people from different ideas back at the
synagogue the morning prayers over and
people are leaving to go about their
daily lives
many are businessmen so for them economy
is key the candidate who offers the best
solutions to Iran's economic problems is
likely to get their vote at least in
this regard Iranian Jews are no
different from their Muslim countrymen